you say cyrus et bienvenue dans ce
nouvel épisode du coup de fil agis de
telle sorte que la maxime de ta volonté
puisse être érigée en loi universelle
alors si tu te demandes qui est maxime
je te conseille vivement de regarder
cette vidéo sur l'impératif catégorique
de compte quand un philosophe allemand
qui souffre genre tous les profs de
philo le dise il ya un avant quand et un
après quand le mec il a un petit peu
bizarre il a vécu toute sa vie au même
endroit et c'est pas vers là où franck
louarn ans et connexes berg bon droit il
perd paumé et quand il est aussi mort
puceau alors quand tu meurs jeune homme
ça va voilà en pis
mais quand tu meurs à 91 4 ans alors
avant courant dans sa philosophie
j'aimerais juste qu'on s'imagine deux
secondes la taille de ses couilles quand
même il a traité pas mal de questions
fondamentales sur la raison théorique
pur comme par exemple comment peuvent
naître les sciences question archi
badass mais il a aussi traité de la
raison pratique c'est en gros la morale
et c'est ce qu'on va voir ensemble
en fait il se rend compte qu'on peut
expliquer nos valeurs ou les valeurs
d'une société en fonction des causes et
des effets mais on peut pas expliquer
pourquoi quelqu'un va adhérer à ces
valeurs là parce que c'est même quelque
chose de super fort d'adela des valeurs
c'est tu t'imposes une conduite à taux m
et en plus on le fait hyper
naturellement cette décision pour quand
elle nous vient de notre bonne volonté
en gros si je prends ma volonté est bien
j'ai d'un côté cette bonne volonté et de
l'autre il ya nos inclination nos désirs
nos humeurs qui subissent le monde
extérieur et la bonne volonté pour quand
elle est autonome ça veut dire qu'elle
se donne sa propre loi la l'habitude de
dire qu obéir aux devoirs c'est perdre
sa liberté mais pour quand c'est
justement l'inversé parce que vu que la
bonne volonté elle se donne sa propre
loi c'est la liberté elle-même alors que
dans nos humeurs et nos sentiments
il n'y a pas de liberté coupable un an
en fait ce que l'on vit dans la prison
voilà que tu livres par la csa et dames
alors ben c'est pour quand nos actions
répondent à deux types d'impératifs on a
dans un premier temps
l'impératif catégorique l'impératif
catégorique c'est celui qui va poser une
action comme nécessaires et
inconditionnelle et ça se pose
a priori c'est à dire avant toute
expérience de quoi que ce soit avant
tout ce qui va dépendre du monde
sensible
en gros ça équivaut à je dois car je
dois quoi qu'il arrive quelles que
soient les conséquences
et c'est pour ça que c'est a priori est
donc la seule chose qui va déterminer
mon action c'est la morale or vu que ça
a priori avant ça peut mener à des
conséquences complètement pourri mais
quand il s'en fout et dira que ce qui
importe c'est que la conséquence des
actions a un caractère moral par exemple
pour quand c'est pour ça qu'il faut
toujours dire la vérité quelle que soit
la situation
ce qui explique en partie pourquoi il
est morte plus haut ben moi je veux un
truc sérieux un mot cherche pas du tout
un truc sérieux jusqu'à poubelle verte a
senti la caisse que j'ai l'âge et l on a
parlé d'un nouveau pénis ou pire
oui bien sûr anne tu peux venir
s'appelait anne l'arrêt dans cet exemple
si on se dit oui mais c'est pas moral
car les nazis van tuân franck on prend
en compte une données empiriques donc on
sort de là priori et donc on sort de
l'impératif catégorique
l'impératif catégorique il répond aussi
à trois principes le principe
d'universalité
cela parce que j'étais au tout début
véridique agis de telle sorte que la
maxime de ta volonté puisse être érigée
en loi universelle en fait un peu l'idée
de ne fais pas aux autres ce que tu
aimerais pas qu'on le fasse sauf que là
c'est plus que l'action en elle-même
c'est le principe auquel obéit à volonté
qui à l'origine de l'action lors par
exemple c'est pas dire aux nazis où sont
les juifs mais c'est le principe de dire
les vérités principes d'humanité
il faut traiter les autres toujours
comme une fin et jamais comme un moyen
principe d'autonomie la loi morale
s'impose à nous par nous mêmes
c'est ce que je vous expliquais plutôt
bonjour mesdames et messieurs bienvenue
dans le sable chaud
le moi de jouer le jeu et de faire beau
à la fin cette question pour y répondre
dans les commentaires
sur cette image david sauver emilie d'un
incendie
selon cet acte relève t-il d'où
l'impératif catégorique
réponse en fin de vidéo ça c'était pour
l'impératif catégorique mais il ya un
autre type d'impératifs c'est les
impératifs hypothétique les impératifs
hypothétique eux ils arrivent du coup a
posteriori c'est à dire après les
expériences après les éléments empirique
donc c'est quand il ya de l'empirique
dans sa décision ce qui fait que autant
l'impasse est catégorique et
inconditionnelle autant les impératifs
hypothétique sont conditionnelles en
gros c'est si j'ai tel but
il faut que j'agisse de telle façon
genre si j'ai froid je mettrais un pub
ça fait partie des impératifs
hypothétique ben moi je veux un truc
sérieusement les points bas ça tombe
bien moi aussi j'ai un truc ça
quand un acte moral c'est un acte qui
répond à l'impératif catégorique du coup
s'abonner à cette chaîne ça peut être
moral si vous voyez comme une fin et non
seulement comme un moyen d'apprendre des
trucs et de je l'espère fasse un bon
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu vous
envoie du love ella pis vous avez pu
remarquer par rapport aux autres choses
qui m'a plu c'est à des années lumière
de ce qu'on aurait pu le penser
machiavel qui est juste ici on aura
l'occasion de reparler la morale et de
voir que ba la conception française
propose par exemple à cette désignation
cariste le sauvetage de dab et ne
répondent pas d'impératif de catégorie
en effet on peut voir d'abord que david
un gros paquet et qui me lit et
extrêmement attractive
au delà de ça on peut voir un bébé aussi
dans le fond de l'image qui ne sera pas
sauvée par d'habiles david a donc sauvé
emilie dans le seul but de coucher avec
elle il a donc considéré emilie comme un
moyen et non comme une fin